holy bunco's kids look out the keep it
moving tour is adding new dates
we're coming to a city near you
come and see us some stand-up and we
play ayg at the end of the show with the
crowd we answer your garbage questions
we've got some trash so far but i know i
know
there's deeper garbage out there around
the country oh yeah so come on out and
see us kippy tell them what they need to
know oh baby we're all over the place
tejas baby
uh september 21st will be in san antonio
texas september 22nd we'll be in houston
texas september 23rd through the 25th
austin texas for the moon tower comedy
festival and i ain't done yet august
26th will be at fort dallas fort worth
texas what then we're bringing it back
to long island baby what and all uh
september 30th and then we're coming
home the boys are the chickens are
coming home to roost baby
october 27th we're gonna be in
philadelphia pennsylvania and then back
down to tejas uh november 5th through
the 7th for skankfest south get those
tickets the link will be in the
description welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
ru garbage it's a little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find it if they grow up to be classy or
if they're just a big old piece of trash
oh yeah i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at aunt tooty's basement she's been
all over me why because she knows we're
going down a wildwood for the weekend so
yeah she keeps trying to set us up with
a couple of ladies down here she knows a
couple of rods i told her i was like
listen i'm in a relationship he's
mentioning oh no you are going to love
these girls yeah what happened 50 55
deuce deuce and a quarter
we'll see what happens what if we would
be playing a pickup football game what
the [ __ ] my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he is the ceo of
are you garbage he's an international
businessman he is not to be trifled with
ladies and gentlemen give it up for my
good pal mr kevin james ryan hey gang
happy to be here as always please make
sure you rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube and as
you know those numbers are true the roof
true the [ __ ] roof baby and then i
would be an [ __ ] if i didn't bring up
www.patreon.com you mean the greatest
website of all time
if i hear someone out there talking [ __ ]
on patreon.com i'll [ __ ] come see you
for sure uh guys patreon you can sign up
you get bonus episodes of ayg episodes
of hard feelings which is a completely
different podcast uh and then we do live
streams every month with our top tier
members it's a good [ __ ] time we put
clips of the live shows up there
extended versions it's a whole [ __ ]
thing check it out yes sir how about a
nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he's the magic man he
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what up
dudes no t-bone chilling having a we got
a great guest i'm fired up beautiful day
survived a hurricane it wasn't [ __ ]
some [ __ ] [ __ ] gang we could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us for the first
time today he is a very funny stand-up
comedian and podcaster he has an amazing
podcast called negro please radio what
was that
that's the title he said i can say it
and also has a fantastic album out right
now called off script but the big
question about his mind today is he
garbage we are about to find out ladies
and gentlemen give it up for the one the
only mr chris allen yeah hey what's up
guys thanks for coming buddy
thanks for having me yeah man for sure
it took a while we got there we got
there we're supposed to happen a couple
of tv we were trying to schedule and i
was out of town a couple of times you
know traveling international business
kind of stuff understands checking on
the things overseas yeah securing some
more funding so uh
making a deal with the taliban
toby ain't cheap all right
um but yeah we got it to work and then
it almost didn't happen today yeah this
guy's coming up on trains came up on the
train track yeah man it's pretty classy
give us give us the full story because
you're from charlottesville i live in
charlottesville i'm from rochester new
york okay born and raised there
uh went to private schools and [ __ ]
private schools yeah man yep
like expensive private schools are just
like
like the public schools so bad there's a
relatively cheap option no they were bad
but i was so much of a [ __ ] my dad was
like we got to get this kid out of here
this kid's going to get his ass he's got
to get killed he's going to be
embarrassing me all over the town that
was i was that was a big nerd man really
yeah because you're like a big dude
i used to play football or anything no i
should be very very skinny man very
nerdy dorky kid um the last public
school i went to was sherlock middle
school right
was the mascot of shalott middle school
i wasn't there long enough to find out
the nerves the bakers
i got tripped down an entire flight of
stairs almost broke my ankle did i had
to low crawl to the nurse's office i had
dust bunnies all over my shirt
people were laughing at me and i
honestly i think the low crawling is
probably why i joined the military
dude i haven't heard the word dust bunny
in 30 years who tripped you some kid i
was running to my latin class
i would have tripped you i got to get
the latin class i got to get the latin
it was probably the principal
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] running to your lat latin
class got tripped down the flight of
stairs and my dad was like we're calling
it is rochester bad or you is it like a
tough is or is it i've never been it can
it's you know what i like in rochester
to a smaller baltimore it's got some
it's got its nice parts but rochester
definitely has its problem areas yeah
they'll see the areas yeah so i grew up
in the inner city around like a lot of
black people but then i was um i was
fortunate because i grew up with a very
diverse background like i said i grew up
in the hood all black people went to
private schools nothing but
mainly white people so i've learned how
to deal with all types of people at a
very very young age what kind of house
did you grow up in in rochester single
family home single family home yeah we
used to get made fun of people used to
say uh that we
we thought we were white because we cut
our grass
well hey stereotypes of stereotype i
guess look at him i heard somebody said
about my dad look at him he think he
white he's
like [ __ ] we own this house that's why
we're cutting grass we're homeowners
what um
sounds like a bad neighborhood um did uh
what did you would your parents yeah
what's your way to do my dad's private
school you had to do something to get
your cash
my dad saved a [ __ ] ton of money he was
a cheap my dad was one of 18.
why
yes holy [ __ ] one of 18. so he he
learned to be very thrifty at a very uh
yeah he's gotta be he started working
when he was like seven years old [ __ ]
like that
yeah man so he went to uh he went to a
trade high school he got into the
printing business and they used to do
like uh uh advertising um
um what the [ __ ] do you call it um they
said like um circulars they said edit
all the photos for kodak this is back
when bill cosby was their spokesperson
geez that kodak the kodak i remember
jello pudding pops yeah you don't
remember when uh when uh you can't eat
film so he
blocked it out bill cosby was like their
guy real i don't remember that yeah it's
so funny man because like what my dad
used to do back then anybody can do on
their phone now yeah
he used to take me to his job he goes
because bill cosby has a lazy eye right
yeah watch this i can change out his one
bad eye and put in the new eye so he
would just cut and paste the good eye
over the bad eye and i thought that was
so cool but you can do that now yeah
yeah
every nine year old does that right
taking the red out of the eye [ __ ] like
that um my mom was a stay-at-home mom
for a lot of times okay but uh she would
take somebody he had to be doing okay
yeah i mean if you've got to stay at
home oh how many brothers and sisters
did you have uh two um sisters and two
adopted sisters really they adopted yeah
man damn my parents are dope that's
[ __ ] sweet they were dope my parents
are dope yeah so it's me and my two
younger sisters and then uh they we they
adopted two uh other girls where did the
two girls come from um just other
families from uh the city of rochester
really yeah did you guys know their
families um yes and then their parents
were in a bad situation they yeah yep
that's awesome yeah this guy's a hero
that's great my parents my parents are
great i think as we got older and moved
out my mom got the empty nest thing she
started doing daycare at the house and
all that type of [ __ ] yeah they still
they get bored as they get older yeah
yeah are they still in the same house
that you grew up dude same house same
phone number
all of that man old school that was
still cutting the lawn say still cutting
the lawn
they even cut like my dad pushed him
over righty mower push yeah yeah please
it wasn't electric was it no actually it
was ah
that's why they were making fun of you
yeah you're plugging it in to cut the
lawn you're gonna run out of cord mr
allen
i'm still terrified now when my dad
comes to my house like i have to go out
edge the lawn make sure everything he
runs a tight ship oh my dad my mom was
the same way if they come to the house
my mom is the type she won't say [ __ ]
while she's there
but like when yeah when she leaves she
goes hey i noticed the the dishwasher
was a little dirty yeah i don't wipe the
outside of the dishwasher
like really like stuff like that my mom
was like they can't let that [ __ ] go as
they get older too no i noticed i
noticed there was a couple of dirty cops
around yeah man that's how my mom is you
keep the lawn tight now though
you know his dad's coming well my dad
comes but i have somebody cut it for me
man my man that's what you gotta do i
like it yeah that's a [ __ ] there's a
black man in the south having a white
man come cut my glasses
great you got a white guy a white guy
stand out there on the porch and watch
him the whole time drink it i'll drink a
tea and everything
yeah don't be stealing nothing [ __ ]
hey boy
you missed a spot
he's got a mint julep yeah you're
dressed like a plantation
[Laughter]
that's right chad that's right don't
miss the edges my dad's coming
bobby's coming get those edges i got a
steer sucker suit for bullying purposes
yeah man i don't [ __ ] around man oh damn
that's great yeah i'm doing pretty well
i got a white landscaper all right
that's [ __ ] i mean i don't know
anybody else you made it baby
dude i had a weird landscape situation
happen this might be boring but um dude
actually this is what the show is about
my y'all got so overgrown to the point
where i was two i was afraid to do it
myself because i live out in the middle
of nowhere there's snakes there's bears
and [ __ ] i was like i'm not doing [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that so i called this random
guy he left he left a card in my house
i'll call him one day he's gotta be
there at like two o'clock he doesn't
come to like 7 30 on a friday i'm like
why the [ __ ] would you come to my house
at 7 30 we're watching a movie yeah i
don't you know i don't want to deal with
this so i go out there he goes oh yeah
we'll do it tomorrow i'll do it tomorrow
i thought he was going to give me like a
week or so to decide dude he showed up
the next day with his family his face
his family it's a it's a hispanic guy
out there it's him his wife and three
kids and one of them was like my son's
age
and we were cutting the grass
and i'm like this is i felt horrible man
i couldn't even go outside i was like i
can't we're sitting there i'm watching
my son play video games and there's a
kid his age outside sweating if it would
have been a white family you would have
thought a lot oh we would have the whole
family would have been out looking at
them i would have went instagram live on
that
yo what up i got my white family they
out here
[Laughter]
damn that's what's up little white kid
pulling weeds
take that [ __ ]
how's it feel
let me ask you this on the landscaping
tip what day does he come the guy now
what day does he come
dude they came um they come every
whenever they want to like you okay
they came two days ago actually okay
they cut it in they cut my grass in the
rain which i [ __ ] hate yes it gets
muddy it leaves the tire marks and [ __ ]
because they say
it's bet the like the
what is it like the the good days are if
they come and cut it on a friday or a
thursday to get it for the weekend ah
okay cause i my mom we get ourselves
something to show it off on a weekend
yeah weekend a little bit
my parents get this cut on a monday and
i know they got a discounted rate for
that
i need to look into that
he's
i want the whole white family there
friday yeah that's extra if you want the
wifi
oh that's good stuff man i love it and
what so what is your uh what do your
sisters do um my one sister she just had
a baby today man congratulations
congratulations my uncle again for the
third time so uh yeah but she works for
um she does a lot of non-profit stuff my
other sister she does more like um
more of this office kind of stuff but
again
they really like to help the community
because for a while they work together
at like a um they worked at a a youth
home together you guys are like [ __ ]
superheroes what the [ __ ] we're just
good people man i am but how did you
they're all up in rochester they're
still in rochester how did you wind up
in charlottesville so um i graduated
high school june 1998 and i was like you
know what i don't want to stay here i
don't want to go to college so i joined
the military i joined the air force
right and i was like i'm going to do
four years i'll have money for school
i'll get out i'll be 22 i'll be done
and
i ended up doing 20 man just 20 years 20
years end up doing 20. yeah i spent the
first five years doing um maintenance on
radar radar stuff which was fun a lot of
guys i was in tech school with uh they
went to my first base so it was just it
was just me and my buddies working a
night shift playing basketball playing
halo every [ __ ] weekend and where was
that in rochester that was at luke air
force base in in um in phoenix arizona
oh phoenix arizona yeah so um
yeah i was there for about five years i
met my wife we got married um and then i
went to korea in 2005 for a year really
so i got married south or
north
south korea keep an eye on this guy yeah
people always ask that
live a little buddy go north huh
but i got i got married and two weeks
later i was in korea for a year man did
she go with you no she was she stayed in
phoenix damn is she from phoenix from
phoenix is she in the military as well
i've no i never dated any any woman in
the military man she was a townie towny
really yeah sevilla civvy where'd you
meet her and uh you guys like basketball
at all yeah you guys remember dan marley
thunder dan marley he used to play for
the phoenix suns back in the 90s no
thunder day and mario yeah dan marley he
was like that three-point specialist but
he had a um a lounge and it was
it was brown sugar hanging out of dan
marley's down yeah yeah dan
and car wash
[Laughter]
but he had he had a lounge called dan
marley's nine lounge and thursday nights
was black night it was brown brown sugar
thursdays man they used to get dude they
used to do that [ __ ] in the 90s and 2000
no
brown sugar sundaes yeah yeah dude the
uh columbus funny bomb was like that on
thursdays they would have like the
regular show and then it was urban night
so you would see like the first show
come out and then you would leave the
show and it was nothing but black people
waiting to see
delay show on sunday yeah man it's crazy
man she was just in there hanging out
just said we're just in there hanging
out it was dude it was one of those
stories where like i didn't want to go
my buddies had to make me go i ended up
meeting her and uh the rest is kind of
history yeah yeah i was seeing somebody
at the time but it was almost over we
extreme numbers i felt bad i was like we
can't talk until it's over i broke up
with my old girlfriend and um this is
back when i had a house phone so i
deleted my
at the time
or what
i had to call this phone he bragging
yeah
he looked at me like hey i had the song
i had the sony 900 megahertz doing it
did he mention the white landscaper what
are you asking him for yeah
so yeah yeah i broke up with my
girlfriend uh me and her we kind of just
you know my wife and i we never really
truly ever were like dating it just kind
of evolved from being a friendship into
a marriage it was yeah it was very weird
geez yeah not weird but it was just kind
of nice yeah it's unique i mean to be
like oh we're friends we're married i'm
going to korea
yeah it was five years of us just kind
of like slowly becoming um
exclusive nice
were you gonna say that you deleted your
old girl's number off the speed dial so
what happened was like i was like we
can't talk so i deleted my now wife's
phone number out of my cell phone i was
like i can't do this
i broke omar grew up and i was like damn
i don't have that girl's number and i
was like holy [ __ ] i called her on my
house phone so i went through the call
log on my house phone and boom her
number was in there and
we kind of started talking again and
we've been together ever since man man
if you would at some for some reason
deleted that or the phone would have
broke or died your whole life would have
been different different yeah a whole
different life man how crazy is that i
was supposed to go to a different base
too like in tech school i was supposed
to go to um i went to tech school in
mississippi i was supposed to go to my
first base uh in georgia was moody air
force base and halfway through my tech
school they go oh you're getting
diverted you're going to phoenix arizona
so i ended up going there and yeah it's
just very in the military man it's very
weird how you can kind of re you can
really see how your life can change
based on the assignments that you get
man so yeah if i would have went to
georgia i would have met somebody else
had a different
trajectory in my life man so i'm very
thankful that i went to uh luke air
force base met my wife and i'm here now
so damn crazy yeah man and how was south
korea
i had a lot of fun man a lot of drinking
uh over that year i had like three or
four of my really good buddies come over
we drank every [ __ ] weekend man
really we just drank and drank and drank
what is it what are they drinking
yeah yeah dude anytime i should [ __ ] you
up
oh you guys had it before oh korean
barbecue yeah i got a couple of korean
friends what do you mix yours with oh i
don't whatever they hand me i don't know
it's have you ever had it yeah you can
mix it is it like a right it's like a
rice i think it's something like a rice
it's a rice liquid it really has no
taste and you can you can mix it with
anything we should mix it with gatorade
really yeah dude mix in anything with
gatorade
that's the first check right there dude
fixing any liquor with gatorade or coke
is trash we were just talking about how
the gatorade is too thin it doesn't [ __ ]
yeah yeah man so i had a fun i had a fun
year over there came back um went to um
uh colorado for about a year then i got
um how are you what's what's going on
with the girl at this point
with your did she go with you to
colorado yes i get back from korea i
pick her up i go we go you got married
and then you went to korea for a year
and what was she like about that what
the [ __ ] you leaving for a year but she
was at home with her friends and family
so it wasn't that big of a deal okay she
was at tommy's nine lounge
yeah trying to find somebody else
um yeah so i come back i pick her up we
go to colorado we stayed there for about
a year and not to bore you but the
military they like to retrain people and
i have made sergeants so when i got back
from this from korea they were like hey
you're on this list you might want to
retrain and if uh if you don't pick
something you might not get picked but
if we need you to then the air force
will pick something for you and i was
like [ __ ] that i don't want that to
happen so i picked the intel job a few
months later i was down and um
good fellow air force base in san angelo
texas which is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
san angelo san angelo dude [ __ ] heard
of that sounds hot the airport is
literally just one it's one small hangar
that's it
one small hanger
the person that took my ticket at the at
the at the shore at the door i've had
this yeah so you get to the [ __ ] he's
also the pilot to ts everything it was
so scary dude i get there he checks me
in he checks me at the gate i look
outside he's literally putting the
[ __ ] luggage on the plane yeah dude
we walk out there he's putting he's
living i was like do you do everything
here sure dude i was in like rochester
minnesota somewhere tiny little same
thing it was like a garage with like two
doors like that was like terminal one
and terminal two and we were we i was in
line
waiting at the tsa line because the tsa
person wasn't there yet like she didn't
even get to work and like there was a
line of people she probably drove uber
or something
hippie
tippystamps.comstamps.com i'll say it
one more time
stamps.com hold on let me say it
stamps.com yes sir why do you want to
waste time with the uh at the post
office i don't stamps.com you don't have
to you get everything done right there
right then boom bang we did it for all
the cards unbelievable product
unbelievable service they have amazing
discounts for ups and usps you got to
get on at kippy straighten them out yeah
guys stamps.com saves uh businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money and
business small businesses baby the
backbone of this country salty earth not
these big corporations i'm talking small
businesses you know
uh they bring the service of usps and
ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business i mean
whether you're sending invoices if
you've got a side hustle going on
sending out orders products anything
it's easy peasy lemon squeezy uh simply
use your computer to print uh official
us postage stamp 24 7 for any letter
package or class of mail anywhere you
want to send it once your mail is ready
you can schedule a pickup or just drop
it off whatever you want whatever is
convenient for you stamps.com has you
it's a no-brainer saving you time and
money it's no wonder why nearly 1
million small businesses have already
used stamps.com a million i mean what
are we doing crazy
uh with stamps economy get up to 40 off
post office and up to 66 percent off ups
shipping rates that's crazy uh there's
no risk and with our promo code garbage
we'll get a special offer that includes
a four week trial plus free postage
and a digital scale they sent the
package to us we plugged it in set it up
we're running we're cooking baby it's
out the door and when we dropped it off
at the post office we weren't in there
waiting around we walked in with our
stuff we dumped it right in the bin and
we were out of it out of there no
long-term commitments or contracts so go
to stamps.com click the microphone at
the top of the home page type in garbage
that's stamps.com promo code garbage
stamps.com never go to the post office
again gang let's talk about
ladderlife.com
and these uncertain times you want to
make sure that you leave your family in
a good spot you got to get life
insurance especially term coverage which
is surprisingly affordable these days
and the people at ladderlife.com can
help yeah guys uh the world's bonko's
right now everybody knows that you got
rising cost of living people got student
debt you're trying to buy a house what
are you gonna you know you don't want to
leave your your your kids or your
partner in a big financial crisis you
know what i mean you can't be doing it
you gotta you gotta keep a good house
you know what i mean uh ladder is 100
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for three
million dollars in coverage or less
three million beans it's a nice chunk of
change you just need a few minutes and a
phone or a laptop to apply ladders smart
algorithms work in real time so you'll
find out if you're instantly approved if
you prefer to talk to a person you can
do that as well of course they got you
their team of license agents licensed
agents doesn't work on commissions so
they'll help you and not upsell you
no hidden fees you can cancel at any
time get a ref full refund if you change
your mind in the first 30 days what are
we doing pretty nice uh and ladder
policies are issued by insurers with
long term proven histories of paying
claims they're rated a and a plus by am
best yikes i mean that's top-notch
top-notch finally life insurance costs
uh more as you age so now's the time to
cross it off
take advantage take care of it so all
you have to do simple go to
ladderlife.com garbage today and see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage you know it you love it
ladderlife.com garbage gippy buddy how
about our good friends over there at
manscape is that manscaped it's
manscaped you got the 4.0 out there now
the lawnmower ceramic blade you got the
light you got a powerful motor quiet as
a mouse unbelievable power trims your
right up listen
you can't be going around these days
with the grass growing out of the
[ __ ] lawn now get your pubes in order
you got to get your pockets in order
straighten it out down there and you got
to get on manscape baby they do it nice
yeah uh look no further uh for look no
further than the performance package 4.0
from manscape that has just taken off
not only the us but canada the uk across
europe australia south africa singapore
i got one you got one t-bone's got
they're clean and everybody's using it
all over the world forever doing the
lord's work fresh uh inside the package
you'll find their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
the weed whacker ear nose and hair
trimmer unbelievable
why stop at the balls you know what i
mean come on
you'll get the crop preserver ball
deodorant crop uh reviver toner
performance boxer briefs which are
top-notch by the way top notch um
it's easy-peasy it's the fourth
generation trimmer also features cutting
edge like you said ceramic reducing the
grooming accidents i was an idiot back
in the day i used to use a blade and
cream i didn't know what i was doing my
dad never showed me how to shave my
penis
he was at the door
uh like i don't know it's got the light
on it it's waterproof wherever you are
you do it in a cave if you wanted to do
it in the shower it's great no mess i
know all right down the drain easy
forget about it um
so guys here it is you get 20 off plus
free shipping 20 i'm talking 5 10 bozos
15 19 20 20 uh and free shipping which
is how they get you the free shipping
you're like oh you buy go to buy
something add shipping it's 48 dollars
not with manscape out the door
um with our promo code garbage at
manscaped.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code garbage at
manscape.com your dick and balls need
some help they all do i need it you need
it he needs it it's changed my life if
you got a partner treat your putt do it
don't do it for you do it for your
partner no one wants to go rooting
through the bushes to find the twigs you
know what i mean i know uh your balls
will thank you one more time uh use
promo code garbage at manscape.com now
back to the
yeah that's all those towns are man it
was it was a city town i was there for
about nine months come back i pick her
up we go to vegas
um i'm stationed in vegas i'm working
with
these drones can't really get into much
of that yeah yeah yeah yeah leave that
chat that's all yeah that's that's when
the classified part of my career started
so i'm doing all this intel stuff really
cool stuff this is that's the first time
i felt like man i'm actually making a
difference here on the war on terror
terrorism i'm actually like we're doing
a cool mission it's a lot of fun
and that's also where i started comedy
nice so yeah he's on stage later you
guys ever been on a drone strike
guy knows what i'm talking about
i was at a wedding last week
it was weird because we would do crazy
[ __ ] and then i would literally leave
work and then go to a mic yeah well
that's probably like part of the coping
mechanism of like hey i'm doing the kind
of this heavy [ __ ] that i didn't
anticipate you know i need to tell some
dick jokes or something you know yeah so
i started doing comedy there um a lot of
fun a lot of cool guys out there my
buddy brant tobler man he used to have
like um
doug benson used to do these backyard
shows shows for him he would get doug
stanhub
i know the name
yeah i know i know that guy yeah yeah i
think uh brandt did a um um um
what's it called uh this isn't happening
this yeah or this is not happening yeah
this is not this is not happening yeah
yeah with our favorite host roy wood jr
i love roy that's one of my favorite
dudes shout out to that was just a shot
at arya
[Laughter]
we love you ari um all right let's get
into some [ __ ] ru garbage here i love
it
how do you want to do it you can take
the lead on this i mean you want to go
now do you want to go i want to talk
about rochester a little bit i know you
can't say the name of the street that
your parents are on because they're
still in the house we like to find out
what what was it a street was it a
boulevard was it a road it was a street
street yeah was it a number
no okay okay something streets wasn't
there all right what was the name of the
grocery store that your mom went to oh
you don't even want to know you don't
even want to know this is the best
grocery store in the world okay wegmans
what god damn it probably what's going
on
military white landscaper this guy's all
clay i went to school with jay wegman
who is now like the vice president holy
[ __ ] he was in the private school oh
yeah i went to jail i went to school
with jay man what kind of deal on cold
cuts can you get
all right hey i'm with you man i love
some boar's head meat
are you is that what you buy now boar's
head if i had a good weekend if i saw a
couple shares i'll splurge
otherwise it's deets and watson or
nothing [ __ ]
watson damn this is my podcast
specific cold-cut brands oh yeah
buddy shout out to the and buffalo
[ __ ] boar's head that'll [ __ ]
knock your socks off i gotta tell you he
works at the plant in memphis
wegmans is pretty good
so that's where they grew so you grew up
going to wegmans but all wegmans wasn't
always what it is today man sure it's
probably a little true but i mean it's
the premiere yeah it's the it's the gold
standard of markets i think it is what
do you shop at now though in
charlottesville food lion
that's going in a file mr allen
god damn that shit's not clenching i
don't i don't like food they've had a 60
minutes expose that's not a good look i
don't know i'm not a fan there shouldn't
be an animal in your supermarket no i
remember they got caught re-changing the
uh the expiration dates on meat
i probably ate a lot of that meat
i don't know why everybody iced me on
that yeah it was a little too real
kind of warned the consumer here have
you ever been into wegmans in brooklyn
no yes i've been to the wigans in
brooklyn but i just had to go in there
and grab something application
[Laughter]
best cookies best chocolate chip cookie
in the world yeah they are foods that's
a pretty good chocolate chip cookie
don't even don't even don't even do it
really don't even [ __ ] try it the
wegmans chocolate chip cookie he's gonna
tell jake
he's gonna be [ __ ] fishy
um dude when they opened up a wegmans in
our area it was honestly like 20 minutes
away and like
we had nothing to do whatever we were
like let's go like i remember going like
let's see what this wegman's all about
just to walk around god you could drive
a car down those aisles disneyland blew
your mind dude oh dude well i had to go
back to a [ __ ] super fresh or
something
pass i was [ __ ] pissed
[Applause]
so wait wait so you guys think the soju
and uh gatorade is is uh that's trash
mixing anything with gatorade come on
come on crazy for sure also like soju is
like ancient [ __ ] you know this like
historical
you know traditional drink mixed with
lemon lime it has it has rules about who
can pour it
does it yeah it has to be the old the
youngest person or whoever has the least
rank in the hierarchy of the crew yeah
that's like a that's like a [ __ ]
the identity of a country and you're not
just gatorade
you're probably like four dudes drinking
out of a bottle yeah you're putting that
in riptide rush
what the [ __ ]
i know this is like it's all respectful
for them here yeah
that's [ __ ] hilarious your [ __ ]
shotgun in it oh man speaking of
gatorade what is your gate what what's
your flavor the white one what's that
one called that's the [ __ ] [ __ ]
person is it the cherry one
white cherries who just here's the thing
column tyrell column
it's so good
that's it's insane to me i [ __ ] on them
i had one yesterday it's [ __ ]
unbelievable i was in i was in the
convenience store and they had it they
never had it it's [ __ ] awesome i'm a
[ __ ] glitch i'm a glacier cherry i'm
a gatorade purist okay
he's gonna [ __ ] hit me i'll be mowing
his lawn next week
he's gonna be having me out there with a
[ __ ] with an edger
and i know you don't like it so you just
got to suck it up yeah that's why i
bought it
damn no man that's too much that's like
code red that's baja blast like i'ma go
go up the [ __ ] middle with it i'm
just lemon
too much hold on a second i'm sorry
baja is there a problem baja blast yeah
it's true
it's a stunt t-bone how much does baja
blast make taco bell since two times oh
he doesn't 1.5 billion dollars billion
with the b yeah right dirt bags are
eating at taco bell it's good stuff
listen
glacier cherries a little bit different
it's just strange to see a white
gatorade it is and that just makes it
trash it looks like horse [ __ ]
how do you know that cut that please
it tastes like it
now i know why i couldn't get you on the
phone last night i'm not falling for
that [ __ ] again
oh baby we got a hot one here
i don't like the white cherry man man i
i like it i won't even bring myself to
try it i that's can i say this what i'm
the same way about cheesecake i will not
[ __ ] eat it i think it's the worst
yeah most overrated dessert of all time
i mean i won't i don't like it look on
it and wait a minute devastated this
is a lunatic
what i don't [ __ ] with cheesecake i
don't [ __ ] with it either i don't i've
never do i've never had it i won't not
eat it it looks like dog [ __ ] i won't
eat it
i think we just found the cliff
it's nuts cheesecake is overrated yeah i
don't [ __ ] with it either dude there is
someone in tennessee listening to this
who just pulled up your picture and is
now cleaning a gun and he's coming for
you that's fine i got something too come
on down here
i don't do yeah he's got nickel here oh
that's good you keep nickel in the house
you got a piece in the house oh dude i
got an ar-15 i got a couple handguns i
got a i have a uh moza nagant i did i
was a huge gamer as a as a as a young
man i used to love that road that
russian uh bolt-action mosin nagant to
the point where i was like i gotta have
one i don't know what that is i don't
even know what that is
the most in the gun look up an m44 rifle
that's what it looks like dude it has a
foldable it has a foldable stock no a
bayonet on it on the side of it
i love white cherry gatorade it's my
favorite gatorade of all time i'm a
weird dude man i'm a gun guy i'm into
all kind of wild [ __ ] man well down
there i mean i think most people also
you saw in the burbs
i have to have it down there where i
live at i need to have a gun
yeah you're in a dicey spot yeah when
the pandemic popped up i bought a
thousand rounds for my ar-15. nice under
my bed right now this guy's bonkers i
bought extra paper towels but
i went pretty heavy into hummus but
hey you do you chris
i don't know you guys but i think this
guy's pretty classy it's classy guy and
uh i think we got enough here yeah not
gun guys aren't you guys from pa i would
be my uh we are my my fam my family is a
bill there was all there was like always
i never just shot i've only shot one a
couple maybe once or twice yeah once
yeah but no i wasn't into them no he
just shot him in the woods
i was trying to shoot fish in a pond
were you yeah but then i found bullets
don't go through water they stop they
slow down super fat when you hit have
you not seen the beginning of private
ryan yeah that's true no i swear to god
yeah i watch it on mythbusters bullets
like don't really penetrate water that
they lose like 90 percent of their so
wait a minute
outside of six feet i believe are you
trying to tell me it's something crazy
d-day was [ __ ] oh hey hey i'm a
patriot just like over here wow jesus
yeah
all right what do you got kip
oh man i'm [ __ ] flustered to be
honest with you oh i got one what may i
sure so single family home garage yes
refrigerator in the garage no
in the basement all right hey what was
in it though nothing but a bunch of
[ __ ] ice
[Laughter]
bags of ice
bags of ice and it was just over it was
like uh over like it was like closing
yeah you could probably put like maybe
like a few burgers in there because
there was just so much ice in there yeah
yeah okay that's trash so it wasn't a
fridge for sodas and juices no we did
have a very old the original bathtub in
our basement the old kind that had the
feet on it yeah we had that in there
with a bunch of [ __ ] in there for years
my dad finally got rid of it what was it
what was in it just old toys and old
[ __ ] like an old bumper and and like
bumper bumper
from his uh what was an uh 85 caprice
classic damn that's what he drove around
in yeah didn't have the light on the
side did it and a bumper apparently no
the bumper that's my fault dude the
moment my dad let me drive his car it
always happens i [ __ ] hit the side of
the house and rip the bumper off
and he didn't get it fixed he got it
fixed when he kept a bumper because he
was like i'll get it fixed later and
never got it fixed we ended up just
throwing it away i don't know why he
kept it man my dad was kind of like that
was the basement finished not finished
okay still not finished
i would be more upset if there was a
bumper in a finished basement true what
i mean
if it was like next to the
big screen it'd be a little weird in an
old bathtub yeah what was the snack
situation at your house when you were a
kid
what did we do
gonna kill me for this but i call them
oatmeal cookies but they're oatmeal
cream pies yeah yeah yeah little debbies
yeah of course those keep them in the
freezer
no should have kept them in the freezer
they didn't fit did you hear them
uh a lot of waffles i was a big waffle
guy hey go eggos i mean
yeah man chocolate chip or straight up
i'm playing man all right good straight
out because i hated that whole wave of
waffles and it was it was really you're
you're kind of your generation
the cinnamon toast remember when they
did the four little ones stuck together
yeah take that [ __ ] [ __ ] out i don't
know i don't give me a buttermilk egg
waffle now that's it i don't know what
the square ones right i don't need my
[ __ ] waffles on a goddamn spectrum
i want either this you got the heat on
you i don't know jesus i don't want to
run i don't even know i don't want to
look over that way
um this is from a friend of ours uh dr
sam rubinoff do you put whipped cream on
pancakes absolutely not i don't even put
butter on pancakes that's crazy
why is that i don't i don't want it just
so just sarah just syrup okay and don't
don't give me any any syrup that already
has butter mixed in it don't do that
i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] do you cut the
do you cut the pancakes up into pieces
and then put the syrup on it only losers
do that
wait look at me dog i'm just saying
you gentlemen you're looking for a
gentleman excuse me i didn't know y'all
had ian finance's brother over there
shout out to auntie ah we love them so
do it do you cut up your do you cut up
your uh pancakes i do i cut them up and
then i put the syrup on them because i
want this
i want the syrup to soak into the to the
fiber of the paint no you just pour on
more [ __ ] syrup
that's very childish all right i
apologize yeah no and it also gets cold
quicker it loses i mean you probably
consume them quicker than the average i
do i pancake pretty fast you have to i
don't want to break yeah that's you have
to here's my theory the heat plays a
role in pancakes my theory on pancakes
the only time pancakes are exceptional
breakfast lunch and dinner
is when they're made at home really no
you go to a diner nah they're never
really that great why not please explain
this i just don't think they're that
cool the thing is i'm not good enough
because my first pancake always looks
like [ __ ] the first one's always always
that's a mulligan yeah
that's why we have more kids i feel like
my son is like the first pancake
i think they're really gonna [ __ ] him up
yeah he's got some bad batter yeah
i got bad [ __ ] folks
that's all that all that cherry
it's all that white cherry gatorade baby
all right i got one growing up uh where
was
the com where was the family computer in
what room what computer you didn't have
a computer at all in the 90s or so no no
no did you need it for school
when i when i graduated from high school
we were barely using computers man what
year did you graduate 98. oh yeah
graduated 94. yeah we didn't really [ __ ]
with him we had a computer in the house
it didn't do anything
it really didn't it took like five discs
just to get it started
i took that [ __ ] to college they were
like oh jesus christ that's why i
flunked out we had like three complaints
we had like three computers in our
school and they only had like the uh
encyclopedia britannica loaded up on
them yeah so you couldn't really do [ __ ]
but they finally got i think my parents
finally got a computer in like two
thousand
two two thousand okay after i moved and
my dad was like yeah we got a computer
you know how to use a computer son
he's flexing on you i was like yeah i
was like i use yahoo all the time he
goes what's yahoo and i'm like that's
like the it was like the google of the
time i'm like how do you have a computer
and not know what it is yahoo is you
obviously don't know how to use a
computer you clearly don't know how to
use a computer nobody nobody was stunned
by that technology and taken off guard
then dads from the 90s because they
didn't know what to do with it no i
don't know what your dad did but we had
multiple computers where all of a sudden
they didn't work
and it was like well you know where all
these pop-up coming from oh they they
they're talking naughty time yeah that
stag movies and [ __ ] playboys that's
all they knew when those guys saw what
they could look at on a computer i think
i caught my dad one time because it
started to auto populate the uh search
bar because i put in h.o and it just
said hot sexy older women i was like
yeah really it's like he's googling porn
like like a 12 year old kid
hot sexy older women i want to see women
with poops
cool boobs that's awesome
oh man huh beautiful
um
oh boy am i that boring no i don't know
what i'm talking about i'm trying to
pick a good one yeah there's just so
many out like you know now then i'm
honestly you're just coming up so classy
that it's like am i classy so far you're
not trashy you're for sure not the only
knocks you have is the gatorade
so you admit it's a knock it's bad yeah
there's the gatorade's bad the white
gatorade no no
don't you [ __ ] try don't
you try to split us up
have you ever won anything
sweepstakes i won some lottery
my own one actually i have two people in
my family that win the lottery
scratchers are like the daily numbers my
aunt won the arizona arizona state
lottery how much 2.9 what shut the [ __ ]
up yeah holy [ __ ] damn she lives with my
parents now though oh no that's always
what happened did she blow through it
her ex-husband did man he [ __ ] her
over god damn it yeah that's [ __ ]
there's never a good story
and then my mom's aunt
and her husband they won the dude they
won their readers digest sweepstakes
they want like 10 million dollars what
the [ __ ] did they show up with the big
check yeah oh they they won the whole
thing man i don't i don't talk to them
but yeah they they won damn holy [ __ ]
why don't you talk about me don't talk
to him because i get into it because
they have the money really yeah
they were like you have peace out losers
yeah ah dude honestly i respect i
respect the move though yeah i hit for
10 mil i'm out 2.9 million readers
digest that's a nerdy way to [ __ ] win
10 mil yeah
come on
cool that ain't ed mcmahon that ain't
the [ __ ] sweeps he ain't showing up
at the house publishers clearing that i
want a jelly bean count one time oh my
god you are a nerd
[Laughter]
you are a nerd how many were there i
can't remember 3 982
my son is like that man
i think he might be on the spectrum
somewhat man yeah he's uh
where was this at
it was in elementary school where i won
the jelly bean count
like 12 jelly beans
that was the only thing i've ever won in
my life yeah i don't think i've ever won
anything either no winning things are
bad luck you don't want you don't want
to win nothing if i won the lottery
you don't you don't want to coming from
a born loser
listen losing's bad kids okay you never
won anything either i mean like a comp
like like a sweepstakes or i don't think
maybe like a 50 50 raffle to beef and
beer or something you know or like
something like that but never no nothing
by chance yeah
i don't think if i won the lottery i
would number one wouldn't tell anybody
and i would not want to be i would do it
privately
yeah because you don't want to be the
lottery winner yeah look at your aunt
yeah you know what i mean there was a
guy in [ __ ] in my in my aunt and
uncle's neighborhood you know classic
[ __ ] you know white trash [ __ ]
family this guy won the [ __ ] lottery
and he it was like a nightmare trans am
is ever trans yeah dude winnebago and
[ __ ] literally exactly he went through
like four iraq z28s in that year
[ __ ] like nine duis [ __ ] blew the
money it never ends
you gotta win privately and do something
the people the people that typically
play the lottery aren't the classiest of
people so when they win it's they they
don't know how to spend the money
millionaires who have generated wealth
aren't going let me play the lottery
yeah my aunt was pretty smart man it's
just the guy she was with really
he was he was into pyramid schemes and
[ __ ] yeah yeah
they [ __ ] gave you those goddamn
pyramid schemes my buddy won in college
or the year we graduated college
uh he was working in
septa
uh which is like the public
transportation in philly and the whole
like accounting department won it was
like one of the like things oh that's
always a nightmare it was always like
the 250 it was like a 200 million
you got to kill everybody there wasn't
there was an ant a few years ago or not
it was maybe this year where
she had sent her nephew to go buy the
ticket he bought the ticket and then but
it was no the ant was the bad one
because she was supposed to split it
with them and then at the [ __ ]
presentation she was like making a scene
on the news like i'm suing them i'm not
splitting it with them and this and that
all he did was go and get it and blah
blah blah blah blah it's it tears
families it's so weird anytime i've ever
like with friends or like co-worker or
like whatever i've been like oh
everybody throw up like 10 but like if
it was like a you know one of the huge
jackpots like everybody throw up 10
bucks we'll go to jersey and get the
tickets before it was like different
states oh that's garbage yeah for sure
surviving to get lottery tickets oh yeah
yeah i am what i am the ohio state ones
up to 48 million let's drive up but i
would go over and say we're like all
right we're buying 50 worth of tickets
or whatever i would always buy a couple
just for me you know what i mean just
where i'm like and then what if you won
or how would you explain that i would
say these are my own everybody has these
numbers
hippies
you would get [ __ ] i would murder you
yeah i'm sorry man yeah
these are these are mine hey that's what
it is hey there's 150 million on the
table i don't care about you okay would
you split it a hundred percent yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] 150 million if i won
that i'll just give me a couple of
million don't you hate the guy when you
get able to kill myself with that
i could do it in the next couple months
you're close with like the four grand
you have
oh i hate the guy who's always like oh
100 million that's really not that much
money yeah yeah
yeah yeah the taxes
it's like suck a dick or the guy who's
like i'll just live up to interest it's
like no you won't yeah no you won't it's
like that's the same guy you work with
like dude i saw you today at lunch put
burger king on a credit card yeah
there's no [ __ ] way
there's no way there's no way you're
living off the juice
you're gonna figure out how to manage
money yeah have you ever put fast food
on a credit card is an unbelievable
article i've i've done it yeah i mean
it's just a car at this point they're
all the same it's just a card now you
still have the guys oh holes
i wrote a check one time at mcdonald's
i've had my i've said this before
i do i used to write
i actually write bad checks on purpose
[Laughter]
oh absolutely i mean like okay no this
is dude this is a hundred years this is
when i was probably 22 yeah they're not
getting it no i don't give a [ __ ] so i
would um get he's got a thousand rounds
of ar-15 all right come get him yeah
come get me so
i used to bank with um credit union west
it's on base and then they had an armed
forces bank that was on base as well
literally right across the street from
each other the same
two different banks i would have no
money we would want to go to a club that
weekend i would go man [ __ ] this i would
go to armed forces bank and write a
check for like 100 bucks they had to
know it's like it's
friday it's friday
at 4 52. yeah i'm writing this check to
my bank that is literally right across
the street they were never like why
don't you just go right across i used to
write bad checks all the time man it got
to the point where i knew like okay
armed forces bank they take about three
days before they cast a check yeah you
can jockey it a little bit yeah you can
you can [ __ ] run with it but then
like target got the little mural you're
one of those [ __ ] machines oh the the
right yeah zip zapper yeah yeah wait
what's that it's like uh it runs the
account number and the routing number
and it's like yeah it's not almost like
a debt it's almost like it almost debits
your account immediately yeah yeah yeah
that's when it became a month yeah
that's when they were like it's a
weekend you don't need that thing yeah i
i went to target a few times they're
like yeah we can't cash this check
there's no money
yeah
yeah dude yikes you never done you never
floated a check oh i've bounced a check
from time to time he just did it about
two weeks ago uh you never you never
used to
when you were younger no what i do so
we've talked i've talked about this
before what i would do i got really good
with uh the processing time on debit
cards and stuff like that of like uh
i would like open up a bar tab and then
i wouldn't put it on i was big on like
getting the cash out i would overdraw my
account on purpose
oh one of those yeah
so like i knew
if i was if it was the weekend and
they're going to charge me 35 bucks or
whatever to overchar to overdraft once
and i didn't have money i would just
take out 500 bucks yeah why yeah why not
that's a monday problem yeah that's
[ __ ] i'll figure that [ __ ] out on
monday it's [ __ ] it's dollar beers
and o'halla hands or whatever i got
really good with uh my the same thing
but with credit card to coming out of my
account if i pay my credit card bill on
my phone it immediately gives me the
credit but it doesn't take the money out
of my account i hate that for a couple
of no but that's i usually when you're
jammed up right now it's good now i got
the card for the weekend at least i
could [ __ ] you know a little
breathing room yeah a little breathing
room you know what i mean anita
breathing room that's so funny man being
a young broke airman was uh some fun
times man who what's your uh talking
about credit how many cards do you have
now uh i have two american express no
just uh a usaa card and like a visa and
what's the what's the limit on them um
one is like uh i want to say they're
both like 12 000. damn
holy [ __ ] it's kind of rich
what about the credit score that's over
it's over 700.
i don't [ __ ] around i mean he is like a
proper adult you know what i mean i got
a kid he's got he's got a family uh do
you get cash back when you use your card
i don't even know how that [ __ ] works
yeah i don't know i don't have anything
good that's good that's a gentleman's
move getting cash back is terrific
is it yeah yeah
that's a bad luck getting five or ten
bucks out of the register yes or
something uh let me ask you this if you
cracked an egg do you eat eggs yes you
crack an egg it's got two yolks you're
eating it you're throwing it away i'm
eating that bad boy yeah i gotta i'm not
i gotta be honest i did i did three eggs
yesterday i don't know
where my local grocer's getting the
[ __ ] eggs from all three eggs were
doubles
it was scary dude holy [ __ ] it was so
much i was guys eating lizard eggs
i was so nervous dude farm next to a
nuclear plant yeah i felt myself getting
stronger
you got you got trees to play the
lottery yeah
i was like
i did the first one i'm like oh look at
that a double i grabbed the second one
and i cracked it again it was a double
and i was like dude i was like reaching
for the third and it was big it was like
a baseball like i'm like dude is that
arms that coming out of the shell i
think this is a double this is i don't
know what to do but it was the last
three eggs so i just [ __ ] jesus could
you imagine being like a gambling guy
and seeing that and go i want to see how
long this can
you're just cracking all the eggs in
your house
[Laughter]
what did you do
it's like i got doubles on three i want
to keep i want to push it i want to
press it that's like cherries never walk
away from the table in a heater
um all right let's see growing up endor
now sprite or seven up
oh man i'm just growing up i'm gonna say
seven up short
seven brady's kids what what what the
[ __ ] now
i guess sprite didn't become cool until
then until the dunk
had this dude that used to sell it
remember the guy was in he was always
under like a palm tree and he's like
seven up now oh yeah yeah oh that guy'd
make you die die in a thirst he was so
good but sprite didn't become cool until
like the proper 90s okay i'm sorry don't
be soda soda steve over here
god damn
are you a root beer guy it's a podcast
about soda you know what every once in a
while i will buy a root beer but i i
don't get like the a w
if uh if i go to a grocery store and
they have like a like an artisan shop
sure i'll go for them yeah i'll go for
an article
wow
uh what's your drink at the movies
just a regular coke man okay i don't
think you can beat coke and um and uh
popcorn man this that
combo can't beat it you can it's called
cherry coke that's how you go you can
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's cherry coke
jerry what are you think you're seven up
and kick rocks will you fatty
share with them the cherry coke what
i'll i mean chris if you're talking bad
about you're drinking white gatorade
this guy's coming to me
i'm a traditional guy i don't like sex
missionaries
and afterwards a nice cherry
white cherry gatorade would you ever go
barefoot in somebody else's house
yes i have okay
worse i've ever seen i saw somebody
barefoot in a
bathroom at an amusement park
dude tell me that's not [ __ ]
described oh he's dead yeah yeah could
you imagine that at least in a while
because when you walk in you can just
see all the splotches oh my god [ __ ]
barefooted i had to get out of there
they almost threw up oh
that's tough when was this are you an
amusement park guy you take the fan of
the amusement park i love i love riding
rides man it's been a while but yeah
where where's the typical allen family
vacation well growing up it was um we
had sea breeze which is a small shitty
one in rochester but we also had a
darien lake that was about an hour away
and we should do that but uh now we'll
go to um busch gardens in uh virginia is
it williamsburg williamsburg yeah it's
trash stop but she's got a special fire
i've no whalesburg is [ __ ] itself
because that's the colonial [ __ ] and
that you know it's all trash as a black
man i don't [ __ ] with the colonials
i don't need to tour any uh slave
quarters yeah no [ __ ] i can't believe
they still do that it's [ __ ] insane
we went on some tour like that and they
had people doing it and it's like they
had this black guy and he was like
explaining to us in this barn i was
about to be like do you want to get you
want to want to get you the [ __ ] out of
here yeah dude the [ __ ] yeah having kids
like oh you guys want to pick cotton
this is like no i'm i'm what
i'm good on that [ __ ] man how [ __ ] up
is that yeah i know people that swear
about uh busch gardens though that it's
awesome you don't like it we think it
now no it's trash okay what do y'all
what do y'all like great adventure which
is garbage they're all they're all
they're all trash the daily amusement
parks
lean trash
i agree they have to i mean if you can
get in with dirty parts that's a tough
one if you can get in with a [ __ ]
soda can it's [ __ ] trash yeah yeah i
mean
a couple cans of coke yeah they're all
a six-pack in the parking lot i think
the thing with busch gardens was and
kevin you can tell me if i'm wrong the
big bad wolf oh we they had the
commercials all the time we were kidding
they would show the big bad wolf that's
all they would show is people going up
and it's just we'd see the commercials
all the time we could never go there and
never go there we went and i remember
develop a hatred for it i love no i
loved it was like we're going and then
my dad was like guys pack the car we're
going to [ __ ] williams you know we're
going to colonial williamsburg in busch
gardens for like whatever the weekend or
the long weekend or whatever and i just
got to remember being like this is
[ __ ] six flags or dorney park or it's
all the same [ __ ] yeah yeah just wasn't
for me i love the food man you can't do
like a fried dough everybody i love it
you know what's great because
like the fourth of july like the summer
carnivals and they have like the
oh just like the hut that it's like the
lights and it's like fried dough
peppers oh yeah they're all turkey
was the last time you guys been to an
amusement park
last time i've been to an amusement park
some minute yeah do you know they have
like uh they have like these food uh
packages you can get now
they have one where it's just like it's
basically all you can eat and drink it's
like 40 bucks and i want to say every
hour you can get something damn yeah
that's pretty awesome that's pretty
[ __ ] dope 40 bucks it's like 40 bucks
and this all you can get
yeah they rank you over the coals 40 is
not bad it's not because
we went i was like man that's kind of
expensive and then you eat one time and
you go
well nine dollars for a car yeah we just
spent 40 bucks if like if one person
gets this then like
her my my wife and son can eat now and i
can eat later it's like it only costs us
40 bucks a week all [ __ ] day yeah so
that's the way to go if you go to a
music park get the all-day package man i
went to disney a couple of years ago now
i'm i am dreading the disney trip man
have you ever been no i'm i'm terrified
but you're gonna get there and you're
gonna realize how expensive it is you're
like yeah it's [ __ ] whatever it's
like thousands of dollars to get down
there and stay and go and then you're
gonna look around and be like how do you
people have this money it's like all
like cut off t-shirts people shirtless
crackers
credit cards
it brings out like the proper dregs of
society i want to go on record i'm a big
fan of the disney corporation i think
they do impeccable work
nothing skis me out more than disney
world the thought of disney world it's a
good time especially epcot i've said you
know tour around you drink around the
world that whole thing he's a good
there's a lot of dirt balls i don't want
to be the dad
who
is just back home whatever state i live
in and i'm wearing a goofy uh
uh hoodie
have you ever noticed think about this
[ __ ] anytime you really see people
wearing disney stuff it's never [ __ ]
clean no the winnie the pooh racing
jackets are always [ __ ] dirty they're
not in shape they're never i know they
all look like me dude it's also a grown
man in a goofy goofy hoodie when when
you're going when you're flying and
you're on the plane and there's like a
grown couple with no kids sitting there
with the mouse ears on next to you and
you're like what in the [ __ ] [ __ ]
tell you
and it's not the kids or the corporation
that ruined it it's the adults that
ruined it did you see the guy
complaining a couple weeks ago not to
get political but he was like they
ruined my experience they got rid of i
guess he was do he was doing the uh the
jungle cruise and they got rid of some
of the racist looking i don't remember
that he's like it took me out of the
fantasy it's like dude you're [ __ ] 50
years old
you're [ __ ] read a book lucy of
disney are you kidding me you should be
googling hot older ladies
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy i don't want to
be a disney dad okay i'm afraid of being
a disney dad here's one what do you got
um
may apply may not apply
have you or do you currently
have any money out to a friend that has
any friend ever borrowed a large amount
of money off you that they still owe or
do you did you borrow any money off a
friend that you might still owe
i have somebody who owes me money really
yeah what are we talking about give me
your number about 350. 350 dollars
mm-hmm how long ago does he owed it to
you probably about 40 years oh so that's
washed you're not getting that but
here's the thing
i learned early on if you're gonna give
this [ __ ] give uh-huh and don't
expect it back right but i had to have a
tough conversation i had to go hey man
like this is this is it like this is the
last time i'm gonna help you i can't do
it anymore why you was he hit me up
it it got it was one of those things
where it was just like hey can i get
this it's like oh no not a problem 20 30
bucks here then it was like hey can i
can i borrow 100 i'm like yeah it's not
a big deal because i was still active
duty my wife was working was was he
paying you back the little ones that he
no never just double dipping just yeah
just never got anything
we're still cool we don't talk it's fine
just yeah you gotta let it go it's just
it's just a wash yeah yeah three fifties
not but you gotta wait somewhat clean
it's it's a wash yeah all right that's
good that's good oh uh i kinda
this is embarrassing oh here we go [ __ ]
it i'll say i don't give a [ __ ]
so
[Laughter]
dude i went what they called tdy down to
georgia one time tdy temporary duty i
was down there for six months i had a
government credit card and i had i was
staying in corporate housing i was doing
it for like i said six months
and i'm living off this government
credit card man i'm just [ __ ] living
it up going out every night you have to
pay it back you're supposed to pay it
back post it yeah you gotta you gotta
pay it's supposed to it's supposed to
even out basically did you get per diem
and all that kind of [ __ ] it's supposed
to even out you're supposed to sell it
up every month so i get back after six
months i'm doing my travel voucher and
there's like a three thousand dollar
balance left on it i'm like what the
[ __ ] uh dude i
did about a month of research i had was
call on the finance office they go dude
you owe this [ __ ] money you you have
to pay and i had to ask my parents i was
like i'm getting in trouble man i i i
need three thousand dollars could you
have gotten in trouble oh they would
have took they would have took it yeah
they would just kept kept his [ __ ]
pace
this is a u.s federal government yeah
it's true if it it would have got to a
point where they go look we're just
going to docupay until this time
like and they'll just take the whole
chunk like hey a little bit yeah they'll
just go hey you're not getting paid for
the next month and a half so until we
get our money figure out the [ __ ] out
yeah but when they owe you money it
takes months to get your money back but
yeah
so i had to ask my dad for the money he
gave it to me and like uh some months
later he's just like don't worry about
that that's just kind of a gift
he's like we never give you anything
he's like just take the money but i
still i so i owe my dad three three
grand man
whatever so sorry dad
i love chris's dad yeah your dad sounds
like a [ __ ] straight shooter oh
speaking of straight you wanna hear the
story about my dad yeah so
i was probably about 10 years old and my
dad worked from three to eleven he
worked evenings and um
he gets home one night and he's looking
at our neighbors back here he goes the
ghost in the garage is he's like why is
the garage door open like they're
they're older older couple there was no
reason for them to be out there at that
time of night neighborhood watches yeah
that's how my dad is man so he goes i
think somebody's over there he kept
looking there with somebody up over
there in their garage he goes upstairs
comes back down with a shotgun oh boy
did you know he had that oh yeah yeah i
knew he had that shotgun and it was like
just leaning up against the wall wall
and i'm like damn my dad's got a [ __ ]
gun holy crap [ __ ] leaning up against
the wall in the scariest way
yeah it's just in the corner just in the
corners and he's just watching to wait
to see this guy and he sees him again so
he runs back he grabs he grabs the
shotgun
runs out the back door dude my dad has
got a gun in one hand uses the other
hand to catapult over the [ __ ] fence
he goes over there he goes get on the
[ __ ] ground right now oh blow your
[ __ ] head off
oh [ __ ] the dude's like yo dude chill
chill chill the cops come my dad has got
a [ __ ] shotgun on this dude's head
the cops come from my neighbor's
driveway and from our yard they're drawn
down on my dad and it's so scary because
i think about this a lot this happened
in probably like 1990. i'm thinking like
there's no telling what would have
happened if this was like
current time no [ __ ] they see a big ass
dude with a shotgun in somebody's head
but they walked up to him slowly they
were like sir just don't move he's like
i'm the one who called they were like
just don't move
and he just stood there the one cop
walked up on my dad they took the
shotgun and they arrested the guy and
they were like we need more people like
you this is great
yeah dude it was [ __ ] oh that was a
[ __ ] super i'm pretty sure my dad got
the best head of his life that night
there's no way my mom was mrs goldstein
mr goldstein
it was a tandem event yeah he had the
yamaha on he left it on too
good that is a dent what are you going
to do
that's [ __ ] awesome yeah that's danny
glover yeah he's too open
dude the one hand jumper oh dude oh my
god
that's like mel gibson it was so cool
man the way he just [ __ ] bolted over
that fence i was like damn my dad's a
badass man jesus yeah man did your dad
ever fight absolutely not never would he
[ __ ] you up absolutely yeah really yep
y'all just saying that gave me
like it's funny because i met so many
guys during the throughout my military
career they would go oh yeah i fought my
dad my dad was a [ __ ] my dad was i was
like yeah your dad's a [ __ ] your
dad's a real [ __ ] if you could beat
your dad yeah dude that's just mentally
it's that's
the best that'd probably still be my ass
my dad he's had both of his hips
replaced he's got a bad knee but there's
no way that's got the
shotgun a couple of handguns and there's
that dad strength yep i would not [ __ ]
with my dad now to this day
i wouldn't even cross my mind to fight
my father never no matter what happened
yeah
all right let's see here fantastic this
is one we've been talking about you came
with luggage yes is it name brand
luggage no what is it i got it from like
tj maxx
it's the best place to get cheap luggage
man it doesn't hold up though it's like
two trips
even the hardware
yeah if you're looking to move a couple
of keys tj maxx is the place to
get some [ __ ] to throw away i wouldn't
be surprised i bet you that's where they
go
percent i spent the money on nice
luggage yeah did you not get an away bag
shout out yeah did you did you see
somebody uh turn in 1.2 million dollars
with the cocaine that washed up on the
beach otherwise yeah i did see that
would you turn it in
it wouldn't
it would be one it would be one it won
okay if it was coke
yeah
if it was
cash
i would take the ca i know i would feel
if i was the guy who turned in
say i found 1.3 and i was the guy who
turned in one million dollars worth of
cocaine
i feel they would be looking at me
to see if i started moving cocaine yeah
i'd be like that's this is the perfect
[ __ ] setup for them to be like yeah
man you went here you texted here i'd be
thinking i have a tail if it was cash
it'd be different you can hide cash i
can't do i couldn't i couldn't take the
coke man i'm not sitting on [ __ ] code
then i'm like you're just sitting on
blow what the [ __ ] yeah no taking it
it was a suitcase full of cash it was
close oh no i would be i wouldn't be
first of all oh i'm not selling it
that's you know okay it's for the
holidays
[Laughter]
labor day's coming up
theoretically merry christmas you just
had a christmas kid i would be more
worried about the drug dealers looking
coming and finding it and i [ __ ] i
wouldn't be the guy that i walked in a
police station i turned in a [ __ ] i
wouldn't touch a million dollars worth
of cocaine like the cocaine guys aren't
gonna see you on the [ __ ] look there
you go i wouldn't do it i wouldn't touch
it i would walk right by it i was the
only i would make a phone call nothing
leave me the [ __ ] out of the little dab
see what's up
just a little bit take your switch blade
out
i can't i've never wanted to do cocaine
but i've always wanted to do that
i wanted to be the guy that go this is
good
but real cops say they don't do that
because if it's poison it'll kill you
that's so true yeah they just stab it
yeah that's good
that guy's hiding from the rest of the
ship yeah you guys want to get a beer
i'll be in the evidence room if you need
it yeah man
i was the only guy in my barbershop that
said i would i would have walked right
by i wouldn't touch it yeah i wouldn't
fight i just dude that much i don't need
people looking at people looking for
that cocaine man people are looking
looking for that cocaine you don't lose
one point two million you have to do
that and just let it go but i think some
of those guys can they go like if
they're moving that much it's like
whatever no here's the thing the guy
who's running the show can afford to
lose that the guy who lost it is going
to get chainsawed the second he gets
back in guatemala exactly he's chainsaw
that ain't my [ __ ] problem well i
mean
the threat of the chainsaw is a pretty
big motivation to find your coconuts you
take better inventory that's all i'm
saying that's so funny because that's
what everybody in our shop said they go
man if you shipping it that big they
have they were like they they account
for losing [ __ ] they really do of course
they do they really do but you get
when you're talking about cocaine you
can't assume like oh this is the surplus
that they're that they wrote off yeah
you can't assume like hey i got the
shortage here yeah yeah
man [ __ ] that huh have you ever owned a
switchblade or a butterfly knife
no but i use i look for them constantly
if i'm honest really
they're so
i think it's cool what about numchucks i
used to make them all the time maybe
yeah i don't want like toilet paper
rolls or whatever no mom dude my mom
used to get so mad i would take broom
handles and cut them and then i would
take shoelaces this guy's not cut the
shoe laces and then my dad is a big hand
like a handy guy yeah so i would just go
downstairs and just nail the shoe the
shoelaces
and my mom was like what the [ __ ] are
you doing
you can't i can't i can't sweep the
kitchen anymore
i made a couple of shields in my day
with some trash cans
yeah great the best was a
[ __ ] uh wrapping paper roll around
christmas time oh me and my brother
getting in the [ __ ] death bomb
saber yeah i pulled out a pair of those
nunchucks in a fight once you did yeah
yeah
uh i got scared and threw him away i
threw him down he did yeah i'll be in
class if you need me getting beat up
with the nunchucks that you made
that's a tough look man
he beat his ass with his own number [ __ ]
craftsmanship too [ __ ] yeah man i threw
him down i was in a i was a a fight one
time and this kid had a chain like he
was like like i'm gonna
the other guy we were watching and he
had a chain and the guy looked at him he
goes if you hit me with that you better
[ __ ] kill me and he just put it down
damn
he didn't have to even thought he was it
was all flash it was all trying to scare
off
dude one night we were sitting um on my
front steps it was me my cousins a bunch
of my friends summer night really nice
night we're just sitting there hanging
out just chilling in rochester and
rochester it's probably like 95 and
we're just sitting there hanging out and
this older dude he's probably like in
his early 20s he comes running by he's
like help me help me help me and he's
[ __ ] i'm inside at that point by the
way until we're on the record all right
that happened very shortly because like
he came running by she's like help me
help me help me we're like get the [ __ ]
out of here
save yourself dude he took off running
right this another guy runs by he has a
bat oh like what the [ __ ] i'm not dude
i'm not making this up next guy runs by
with the chain
third guy runs by with a knife we
[ __ ] run inside have no idea who this
guy was or what the [ __ ] he did but yeah
dude to be i have no idea if that guy
even lived yeah because he had three
people chasing him with a bad assortment
of weapons a knife and a chain he was
the bad guy he was the bad guy man he
[ __ ] up yeah oh he lost the 1.3
million
i saw two two gay guys get into a fight
after they robbed his house they just
happened to stop in front of my buddy's
house right they get out the car they're
fighting about how they're gonna divvy
up this stuff one guy is on one side of
the car the other guy's on the other
side of the car and they're like
flamboyantly gay which is completely
fine but it's funny because they're
yelling at each other they both open a
back door and there's nothing but fine
china all in this back seat really and
dude they just start throwing this [ __ ]
at each other like doing the ducking
thing
so this is one the one guy's like [ __ ]
this do you remember back in the day
when people they thought it was cool to
like decorate their yard they would um
plant bricks in their yard kind of
sideways so it would look kind of
sawtooth and they would put it around
their their bushes yeah yeah and it
would have like the two holes in them
yeah this guy comes up into my buddy's
yard he [ __ ] does this
rips the brick out of the of the ground
goes back to the car he [ __ ] pump
fakes the other guy
jumps up
he [ __ ] launches this [ __ ] brick
hit this guy in the head
he goes down like a ton of bricks the
guy jumps in the car and just drives off
and this guy is laying in the street
blood is just pouring out of his head i
grew up in the hood
we surround this guy with our bikes and
just start [ __ ] and laughing
[Laughter]
laughing at this guy
laughing at this guy i don't even know
what happened we just we just took our
bikes and went out i don't know who
called the ambulance i mean that's just
dumb ignorant [ __ ] like that we used to
do i feel like [ __ ] that like back in it
was just like okay that's your problem
i'll see you later yeah there's also
like no cell phones and stuff like that
it was way different yeah dude
that was a wild fight it was so funny to
see them just throwing dishes tea cups
and [ __ ] back and forth
everywhere when something like that like
you think about it but when in reality
when it happens you're like what the
[ __ ] i know you're like what the [ __ ] is
going we just sit there watching it like
damn
we were oh sorry i'm sorry one night my
dad uh you know we were in the suburbs
and we had just kind of moved down to
the philadelphia area so it's like a
sunday night my dad said come on we'll
take a ride down got kelly drive which
is on the river where the like boathouse
road real pretty yeah yeah like they
have lights on their houses and stuff
like that and it was a summer night and
um
there's a bunch of people out there you
know a little bit of traffic you know
they're like around the park and stuff
like that and all of a sudden this
[ __ ] car flies up next to us and
there's a guy hanging out the window and
like half of his fingers like half of
his hand is sliced off and they're
screaming they're like they [ __ ] cut
my hand off they got my screaming for
the police my dad was like nope nope
later
let's go to dairy queen yeah [ __ ] man
yeah it's traumatic we saw at a niagara
bar we used to do shows at niagara bar
in the east village and there was uh
thompson square park is right there and
it's like thompson square park is like
dicey there's like
a lot of street people there's a lot of
drugs over there there's always just
like people in and out it's real weird
and these two street people got in a
fight and the one guy had like a were
you there like a machete like a machete
was like a legit sword it was a sword it
was like a like they may he made some
sort of he fashioned a sword and him and
another guy were going at it and the
other guy had a six-pack of beer do you
remember
and
he was like if you come at me i'm gonna
hit you with a beer so he [ __ ]
won a beer at the guy's head and he the
sword guy ducked it and he threw another
one at it he ducked that one and then
another one so now but then now he only
has two like he's he shot all of his
ammo but now he's gonna have one i want
to drink these yeah listen man i was
expecting to have two of these so and it
was just like this and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is like 6 p.m and then like the
cops finally like we see like sirens
coming like okay somebody finally called
the cops i think cops went right by it
like they were going to something else i
was like
gotta love the east village baby
this summer's wow [ __ ] that just goes on
man
and then just like it just stopped and
then
just go back like no that never happened
you know i just don't want to be a cop
too man i couldn't imagine like run into
that [ __ ] every single [ __ ] day
brutal you're just seeing people at the
worst time of their lives oh yeah [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] tough look dicey hmm all
right let's see we we let's do a couple
uh
how many more do you got a lot left i
could keep going i got a whole bunch of
fun stuff anybody in your family ever
been on the local news for any reason at
all
yeah my cousin uh she was on the news
because she was a teller they got stuck
up when they robbed the bank that she
worked at
yeah it was cool
i can't remember it's just this is like
you don't get that much of a bank it's
like seven grand maybe plus you hit a
die pack you're [ __ ] yeah
you're [ __ ] yeah she was on there with
the silhouette and the voice and
everything really what yeah oh that's
extra garbage that's a [ __ ] first oh
you i didn't see the removes are you
kidding me no my cousin kimberly bailey
everybody whoa what the [ __ ] now this is
like 25 years ago jesus
holy [ __ ] i've always wanted to be
interviewed like that yeah oh that's
awesome my mom she uh she won like a 500
gift certificate at uh wegmans for being
like their millionth customer yeah
something so they had dude so she was
just running in
hair looked a mess
she looked like complete [ __ ] dude they
had her picture up in the front of a
wagon
over a gift card that's great dude yeah
yeah man i had i had an embarrassing mom
i can't i can't lie she was like the
black mom dude
i'm going to these private schools
she would pick me up like
in the like classic in the robe in the
car twitter rollers in and she's really
tweezing her chin hairs i'm like what
are you doing
what are you doing to me man like i had
this complex of being like the only
black kid in school i didn't want to
look poor and here's my mom tweezing her
[ __ ] chin hairs outside the [ __ ]
gym
i'm coming out of the basketball
practice you know it's like oh my god
that's awesome yeah man my mom
definitely dropped us off at school with
a couple rollers in there
yeah tough luck yeah
she didn't give a [ __ ] man but she
doesn't i love my mom uh all right let's
see have you ever watched a pro sports
game from a club box or sweet level
have i ever i'm trying to
i want to say
no i have not i can't that's a level of
class
get your hands on those tickets follow
up on the other side of that have you
ever attended a triple a baseball game
or a g-league basketball game
dude i uh
well first of all the rochester red
wings are in in rochester so i've been
to that's baseball or baseball okay
countless i don't even think they're not
triple a are they i think they might be
double lane now sounds high school if
you're asking about rochester right
wings yeah yeah dude we used to they
couldn't give away tickets back in the
day so we might yeah none of them can
they would they would be at like it was
so bad like every store
just had
piles of free tickets at the register
yeah yeah yeah and like we were dumb
kids you would take a st a stack of them
and try to sell them to people so i can
just walk into this i can go to the
wegmans as well and just buy it and just
get them for free um
but yeah i used to go a lot and i did
stand up at a red wings game damn
and on the field in between innings from
the mound
from uh from next to the dugouts
and the baseball players are looking
like look at this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
i wanna like do you make like 14 dollars
a year yeah yeah i don't mean more than
you shut up
but yeah dude trying to do like crowd
work to people through that net was not
fun man
sir what do you do for work i'm the
umpire
he's like
yeah it was uh it was not fun but it was
cool being a big sports fan uh baseball
was my first love any time you're on a
pro theater yeah it's f or like a
professional field yeah it's crazy i was
on a football field like this it was
[ __ ] it's like it's a surreal event
yeah isn't it weird like um like the
first pro game that you ever go to you
get there and you go oh the court's the
same size yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
for some reason in your mind you think
it's this big stage when you get there
it's just like oh no this is just a
[ __ ] basketball court that's it yeah
yeah did you have a rollerblades growing
up
no i had a skateboard i had a back to
the future skateboard somebody still you
had a you had a valve eric or whatever
it was like the actual back to the floor
no it was no it was just like this
yeah okay oh somebody's still missing i
was gonna ask if you've ever been on a
bike with rollerblades because that [ __ ]
is wild when you see it what's that on a
bike riding a bike with rollerblades on
yes have you ever seen a kid riding
around on a bike
[Laughter]
have you ever owned a chia pet
no
have you ever bought used tires
no
okay
have you ever been to a dueling piano
bar yes
i lived in vegas have you ever requested
a song absolutely not okay
who likes those [ __ ] places i've been
in college the one popped up in philly
and i'm like all right like everything
and i didn't get it right away i'm like
this these two dudes are way too hyped
to be playing the piano yeah how the
[ __ ] do they know every song that's kind
of creeping me out that's weird
i just need to know a little bit more
about now
um
i know you got the white landscaper yeah
all right who's talking about the garage
fridge at your parents house you don't
have one now do you i have a shed
you know no this is the first time i've
never had a garage in a house that i
lived in you don't have a garage i hate
it i hate not having a garage what's the
driveway is it asphalt or is it rocks or
what is it it's asphalt my neighbors is
rock
it is it's not i don't i hate it yeah
you at least but i like that by
comparison you look better i do because
you got a better driveway i do pull you
got pull no pull no pull sprinkler
put the kids in the sprinkler sprinkler
yeah
that was the best as a kid man driveway
sprinkler oh nothing better
oh man it was better than a pool it
really was i liked the spring excitement
so y'all grew up kind of in the inner
city no we were in the suburbs okay
suburbs of philly
okay
let's see
i had somebody who stole my bike as a
kid uh friend requested me on facebook a
few years ago
you know it was him that started yeah he
rode by my [ __ ] house in it really oh
yeah what did you say to him not a
[ __ ] thing
he was this this kid he was he was wild
man he was a bad kid he was bad this kid
named dre um i don't know if y'all
remember probably not because he might
be pretty young but there was his
redheaded kid back and i want to say it
was the early 90s i want to say his name
was like um eric smith
he killed like a five-year-old kid and
like stuck a stick up his ass can we get
a i think that's his name i think i know
what vaguely remember red hair redhead
kitty wore glasses he looked like a
[ __ ] monster when he was like dead
yeah yeah yeah
eric smith that same dude that stole my
bike when he went to juvie had to stay
the night with that same kid
he came back and told us he's like yo
you saw the remember the white boy that
killed that little he's like he's like i
was in the cell with him he's like i
didn't sleep all night he was like i was
terrified jesus he had dude he had to
bunk with that [ __ ] kid man [ __ ] that
kid should be in solitary yeah no [ __ ]
yeah and that's why you don't steal
bikes
no kidding yeah he stole my colombian 95
man i was upset man
the hell's a colombian 95. that's what
that was i think it might have been a
huffy but it was like the columbia 95
model coffee was all right that was my
[ __ ] dude back in the day huffy was it
they had the gooseneck i had i had the
pegs on the front and the back it had
the uh they had the little thing on the
front of the um front spoke where i
could spin my handle bars around and
they did the gyro yeah the gyro
stole that best christmas gift of of my
life and this [ __ ] stole it what
did your parents say though when the
bike got stolen and your dad with the
shotgun he sees the kid riding her at
the bike i'm surprised he didn't go get
vengeance no my dad is very like he he's
my dad's quiet my dad is very worried
about like i can't say retribution but
my dad is very like don't [ __ ] with them
because i don't want them coming back
here at night and trying something
let's just let it let it die yeah so you
had to go tell your parents hey my bike
got something well he saw it too my dad
was like there's the bike and it's just
like he's not gonna do anything cause my
my dad is very quiet my dad's one of the
nicest guys you can meet but if you piss
him off he will he will kill you jesus
oh dude another story about my dad
please so
you mean the greatest man in the history
of the americans
yeah so my our house
my house sits here right say my this is
my house and there's another street
right here so whenever the the snow
plows would come the edge of the snow
plow would push all that stuff and block
your driveway it would block our
driveway all that heavy [ __ ] you know
like all the [ __ ]
guys
my dad called like hey when you guys
come by my house could you please make
sure y'all don't leave all the heavy
stuff at the mouth of my driveway it's a
lot of work i work a lot of hours you
know please don't do that sorry sir we
won't let it happen again they did it
like two or three more times
we were getting ready to go to my
buddy's birthday party and it just so
happens this guy in this truck comes by
and does it again my dad reaches my dad
is crazy he keeps weapons in this car he
used to keep a do a rusty ass k-bar
knife
military issue
dude it was so [ __ ] rusty it was
green black blue i was like why do you
keep it that way because if i steal
something if i stab somebody with this
[ __ ] they're they're going to get tennis
from there something's happening and he
kept like a galvanized pipe in the back
under his seat too dude it was concrete
cement all kind of gunk in it had like
some weird [ __ ] on the top it was very
medieval damn he reaches back grabs that
pipe
he flags down the uh
the snow plow
grabs the mirror hops up there says
something to the guy smashes the [ __ ]
front window out of this truck
gets back in the car and we just drive
off like nothing happens jesus and i i
asked myself as ice dude i asked my dad
about this to this day he goes that
never happened
[Laughter]
you were seeing she never when he came
back was the stuff out of the driveway
it was out of the driveway baby
my dad was no snow on your yard at all
i didn't know that it didn't still at
the end there's no snow anywhere
it's a guy cutting our grass just like
why did i have
[Laughter]
yeah my dad man he's a he's a very quiet
guy very nice guy very christian guy but
if you cross him or you like treat
people like [ __ ]
night and day man it is terrifying
terrifying
good old bobby i didn't expect to talk
about bobby this much bobby's great dude
i [ __ ] love bobby bobby allen bobby
joe my name is uh chris jones bobby
jones bobby jones yeah i like that bobby
jones bobby jones
middle name bye b jones
when i was uh because i started doing
comedy when i was in the military i
wanted to separate my comedy from my
military career so i started doing uh i
started using my my middle name once
things got kind of serious that makes
sense yeah you got a car now i do what
kind of car uh what do you think i have
lexus okay what do you think
um rav4 no you're down there
really
honda pilot no
it's an suv
no it's not i just said rav4 because
it's kind of like a ah yeah
i i'm gonna i'm gonna go completely
against type go ahead i'm gonna say
prius that's exactly what i had
[Music]
let's go
prius baby
i live in charlottesville and it's about
an hour and a half from uh richmond and
i would do the richmond funny ball when
i was like mc and stuff and you know to
pay for mc is [ __ ] man this is like
yeah 300 bucks and i had a nissan maxima
v6 and driving there every every night i
would spend about 175 dollars a weekend
on gas and i that was just for i was
like man i'm making 125 after gas i was
like i can't keep doing this and plus um
i was starting to go to dc more and that
was getting way too [ __ ] expensive
man yeah yeah so i i had to get
something that was uh way more color
it's black let me ask you about the gas
now
younger you do what you have to do when
you go get gas now do you always fill it
up oh yeah always so you're not you're
not giving me 15 on this 10 on this i'll
say this the only time i ever do that is
like if i'm traveling because some
states the gas is like ridiculous sure
just get yeah like it's like in maryland
or something i'm like [ __ ] that give me
six bucks just to give me she'll still
do six to get out of it just to get out
of here six is a tough look but not in
the prius not in the prius
three tanks
i'll try the white gatorade okay
i know but i i i'm gonna i've realized
i'm an [ __ ] because when i pull up to
a gas pump and i see like 357 i'm like
look at this [ __ ] yeah meanwhile
you're putting six pieces of [ __ ] yeah
but then i go you know we've all been
there oh we've all been there man yeah i
used to i remember i remember going with
like i'm getting a pack of cigs
and like giving the guy like seven bucks
when things were like 450 and being like
put the rest on pump too
aluminum for a long time i gotta say the
lumina it's got some giddy up
yeah
i had a lot of space too and i had to
like the 95 i think it was yeah my mom
had one that was one of another car one
of the first cars that i drove here yeah
illumina shout out to the loom baby
herr's uh the um the steering column
adjuster thing broke so like you had to
like hold the steering wheel
you had to really bracelet
yeah pull the shield out yeah that's a
tough look right there that's it because
if you yeah because you could just drive
it and it would just do this so if you
want to go around corners you have to
like push it up hold it from the bottom
and then [ __ ] turn what though it's
like a flying helicopter
and a constant state of chaos and
aluminum yeah dude it's pretty scary
yeah doing like 55 around the corner
you're inverted
[Laughter]
i think i'm done
i think i've made my decision yeah um
i agree as well i agree i hope we're on
the same page
uh i i think so i think we're on the
same page i believe is this the episode
where they call black people garbage
well we have in the past of course uh
you shoot straight down the middle yeah
um this is uh
since you are a gun owner that i think
this this is from our boy alex danello
on patreon nice uh so when you sign up
for patreon we'll answer your garbage
question on the air
uh this is is it garbage to have an nra
sticker on your house but not on a gun
jesus yeah
that's trash yeah that's like the fake
you know the citadel or whatever do you
have anything like that on the house gun
owner beware of dog anything like that
any any kind of warning or anything no
just by confederate flag that i had
keep it out front yeah this guy's all
over the place
hey i'm with you fellas there's a lot of
them where i live at man still oh yeah
really absolutely just confederate flag
in the yard oh yeah what the [ __ ] oh
yeah where i live at absolutely
absolutely man
do you have a flag in your yard do you
do a flag no no flag okay any bumper
stickers on the prius
it's not a bumper sticker but i do have
one little sticker on the back of my car
what's it say it says bcm gun fighter
it's a gun thing
that's okay it's
like like a like a video game gun or
like a it's like an actual no gun it's a
no it's just this it just says bcm
gunfighter i bought like a sling from
them and it came with the sticker so i
just put the sticker on my car all right
yeah
uh-huh so that's a little
self-preservation where i live at man
people know like hey
sure he's got a of course he's got some
nickel on it it's ain't gonna be an easy
one it makes sense right it makes sense
i completely get it uh this one's from
brendan uh since we're on the top of
cars have you ever had a car you've had
to access through the passenger door
or like the driver or through the window
yeah um
dude the first car i had was a 91 dodge
shadow
um it didn't have a pat it didn't dude
oh god i'm so stupid
it wouldn't start one night i'm at my
girlfriend's house and the window's
halfway down i'm super young i didn't i
didn't know if you slammed the [ __ ] out
of a car door and the window isn't up
all the way it's going to shatter yeah
so i should know that especially those
old floors but it wasn't like airtight
dude [ __ ]
bloated yeah oh they go quick boom i was
like what the [ __ ] so one the car didn't
have ac
so i lived in arizona with a car that
didn't have ac for about three years
jesus christ and then for a few months
it i didn't have a driver's side window
geez there's no rain yeah but still was
there glass everywhere though glass
everywhere it was probably for like
months afterwards
then i bought i bought a window but i
couldn't get the mechanism to work so i
just taped it up oh chris so whenever i
went through the gate i had to open the
door to give the guy my id
this is changing my original yeah man no
that's not how old were you uh 21 22.
i'll give it to you i'll let that slide
a little bit for sure what what about
the fact i was paying 300 a month for
just liability insurance only for that
[ __ ] jesus christ they saw you
coming from a mile away
this is funny the guy the guy i [ __ ]
the guy over who sold it to me he wanted
500 bucks for it but he was going to
korea and i was like oh he's only got a
few days left he's going to get
desperate so i waited like two days
before i got it for 300. and i'm looking
through it got him at the airport
he had a bra for the front of this thing
i was i don't know why a bra yeah you
know
the leather thing right on the front of
it yeah 91 dodge shadow oh you mean on
the [ __ ] on the front those things
dude or such trash why why did i take
that [ __ ] out and try to put it on the
front of this [ __ ] car it's like
literally 2002
and uh this is a 91 dial shadow and i'm
trying to put a bra in the front there's
dudes in the dorms on the second floor
they're [ __ ] laughing at me and [ __ ]
i got about halfway done and that's just
a grill cover yeah i was like [ __ ] this
i just took it off and put it back in
the trunk baby they were laughing and i
was just like why the [ __ ] would i
put a bra
out of a bad luck
bad luck man
i'm i'm all set to render a verdict on
mr allen jones i hope we're on the same
page i think we're on the same page
because as far as unless i was not
another podcast and don't realize what's
going on i only heard a couple of things
and they were early the i mean the
gatorade
is one of the only things that's really
sticking out so i'm saying
he's not garbage he's not garbage you're
a classy guy ah i want to be garbage i
know i know but i mean like the car
thing at the at the buzzer there but i
mean you're 21 you're you're broke it is
what it is i want to be garbage i mean
oh china i mean you got the white
landscaper man i mean it's [ __ ]
pretty good this is bad i probably
shouldn't say this this is bad oh god
i shot a gun drunk
in the city limbs before into the air
just up in the air yeah oh my god
all right what about that is that is
that pretty bad
how long ago was this probably about 15
years ago perfect actually longer than
that probably 17 there you go does that
that's still young though i mean you're
you but invite a good head on your
shoulders in my apartment
shopping at wegmans you know the owner
of wegmans yeah you know the owner of
wegmans private mom was the millionth
customer military service
you know what about okay any loose
toilet seats in your house now like just
loose
no playstation xbox anything yeah that's
not poke that's not hooked up yeah okay
how do you clean a public toilet seat
oh [ __ ]
a bunch of toilet paper
that's what that's what i find you laid
on the toilet paper no i'll just i'll
wad it up a good one
and we'll give it a wipe yeah what kind
of coffee pot do you guys have in the
house now
it's this guy's class i'm trying i'm
trying to give you an hour the only
reason why i bought it because my
parents came to my um when i retired
they wanted coffee so i bought it for
them toaster toaster oven
toaster
i [ __ ] up i have a two slot toaster
that's that's shitty
if any young men are out here watching
you never invest in a two slot toaster
it's a waste of money jesus
that's what it is i'm calling it up the
middle
up the middle no you should be proud
dude yeah you should be proud you're
classy i want to be a piece of [ __ ] dude
it's like i'm not saying you're not a
piece of [ __ ] all right but you're a
classy piece of [ __ ] what about you and
your wife's wedding what was where was
that what was the deal nope courthouse
okay chili's reception oh
come on man
that is unforgivable all right
that's maybe the most buddy took us to
chili's that was it buddy yeah there
wasn't like a like a like a people there
no my buddy joe and his wife jennifer
we're still friends he's retired as well
they took us two chilis for our for our
wedding
now here's the thing okay that's a
little different i know no no he's gonna
agree with me no i know you want to be
garbage but
what would have been trashy about it is
if the reception was actually if you
chose chili's like hey if
what about this i got married in a in a
rock-a-wear long-sleeve t-shirt
nothing
that's pretty bad
that was of the time though if you got
married today
no honeymoon
i'm still getting [ __ ] for that to this
day
we went to korea he was serving the
country that's true and i didn't cheat
you guys got a brita at the house
we you know what we used to but then
they i just kind of
you just do the tap water yeah
so if we would if we came over to your
house because this is a kippy question
we came over to your house and you know
we wanted some water what would you be
giving us out of the just out of the
thing from the refrigerator or us dude i
just i still have nice class clothes you
got side-by-side doors on the fridge
yeah
closing but dude i still do that
probably i'm gonna ask you to borrow
money no my house is so outdated it
looks like the soprano's inside
this guy's classy i'm sorry that's it
chris allen all class oh [ __ ] right
there guys side by sides killed you you
got side by side you doing all right
yeah cure i mean what are we doing come
on what are we
you
doing
a landscape bird yeah come on come on
man that's that's too nice damn and you
drive a prius that's responsible
kid's got a good head on his shoulders
yeah
damn it
uh chris thank you so much for
us
saying
it dude absolutely [ __ ] fun episode
anything you want the folks out there
know you got coming up or what do you
want to plug oh just check me out at
chris allen comedy on all things social
media check out my uh podcast negro
please radio i do another podcast with
my buddy winston hodges called the host
battle podcast uh that comes out every
monday and just yeah check me out on
youtube follow me on social media and
get the album get the album guys yes off
script by uh by helium presents so check
it out fantastic thanks for having me
guys thank you man this has been awesome
kippy what do you got for him guys uh at
comedy on all social media uh you know
check out the live show we got merch
available we got the beer koozies uh
and the the card game [ __ ] check it
out all the links in the description we
love you guys we'll see you next
week peace